ja wirklich verkehrte Welt die Union
lebt ihre anarchophase aus und die
Grünen sind plötzlich die spießigen
Erwachsenen Annalena baerbock heißt die
erste grüne Kanzlerkandidatin der Welt
so entschieden von einem Gremium
bestehend aus Annalena baerbock und
Sekunde
Robert Habeck
nur Harmonie bei denen nur Harmonie Null
Streit ist fast schon unheimlich sind da
vielleicht doch sedierende Globuli im
Spiel nein die Grünen pflegen einfach
noch ja die die klassischen bürgerlichen
Tugenden zum Beispiel der Dame den
Vortritt lassen gegenseitige Respekt
gemeinsam werde ich diesen Wahlkampf mit
Robert Habeck anführen Robert Habeck und
ich zusammen wir haben das gemeinsam im
Team gemacht gemeinsam eine Entscheidung
die wir zusammengetroffen haben Robert
Habeck und ich gemeinsam so was
gemeinsames klappt am besten gemeinsam
Robert Habeck und ich zurzeit und
deswegen haben wir gemeinsam beschlossen
dass ich diese Aufgabe wahrnehmen werde
genau ich habe gemeinsam entschieden
dass ich das mache ist natürlich Quatsch
das spricht schon viel dafür sie kennen
sich aus mit Klima und Außenpolitik ist
eine legendäre aktenfresserin immer top
vorbereitet heißt es also ich sag mal so
total überraschend kam diese
Entscheidung so gesehen wirklich nicht
wobei kurz davor war es schon zu erahnen
Annalena baerbock fuhr mit Polizei
Eskorte und Leibwächtern vor Robert
Habeck kam mit dem Fahrrad zur
Verkündung ja natürlich und dann an ihre
Eskorte den habe ich auch noch
umgefahren andere Geschichte 2012 und
2017 wurden die Grünen Spitzenkandidaten
übrigens noch per Urwahl bestimmt
klar jetzt wo es plötzlich eine richtige
Chance aufs Kanzleramt gibt kannst du
sowas nicht mehr den basispöbel
entscheiden lassen es geht ja nicht es
geht ja nicht und crazy bärbock hat auch
gleich mal ein richtiges
ausrufezeichengesetz Freunde erstes
Interview nicht bei uns also bei den
schnarchigen öffentlich-rechtlichen
sondern bei ProSieben hier so geht
kritischer Journalismus das war toll wir
sagen Dankeschön an dieser Stelle vor
allem an sie Annalena baerbock wir sind
nur zu zweit die Klasse
herzlichen Dank alles Gute
ja von mir auch ja kurz danach haben
sich die Moderatoren noch ein Autogramm
von ihr geholt es wurde muss ich sagen
aber auch mal kritisch gefragt zum
Beispiel wo denn die 50 Milliarden genau
herkommen sollen die die Grünen bald
jedes Jahr investieren wollen wenn sie
regieren worauf Frau bärbock sagt Zitat
das Geld kommt aus unterschiedlichen
Bereichen
dieser Satz war übrigens auch jahrelang
die komplette Steuererklärung von Uli
Hoeneß ich meine gerade bei solchen
Finanzierungsfragen bleiben die Grünen
offensichtlich in ihrem Wahlprogramm
eher vage denn nichts soll die neue
Harmonie stören es versteht man ja auch
meine zu genau erklären welcher
Wählergruppe man was wegnehmen will das
ist halt Gift an der Wahlurne auch aus
Angst angreifbar zu werden entscheiden
sich die Grünen heute lieber fürs
unkonkrete Fehler bin ich wiederholen
sollten ist ein eins zu eins komplett
durchgerechnetes durchfinanziertes
Programm zu haben clever wobei man
fairerweise sagen muss in dem Programm
gibt es natürlich auch konkrete stellen
die Grünen wollen zum Beispiel einen
bundesweiten mietendeckel anziehen in
Berlin ja gerade bewährt Gas geben bei
der Digitalisierung und
selbstverständlich einen deutlich
höheren CO2-Preis also letztlich Reform
die unsere groko seit Jahren verpennt
aber vergessen mal bitte mal das doofe
Land was wird denn jetzt aus Robert
Habeck
[Musik]
okay das ist bösartig Leute das geht
nicht selbstverständlich wird er sich im
Wahlkampf weiter reinhängen der Robert
was denn sonst ist unglaublich was der
arme Mann sich in dieser Woche alles
anhören muss mit Sicherheit wird er sich
einbringen in den Wahlkampf weil er
natürlich auch als Persönlichkeit vor
allem dann ein gewisser Wähler Magnet
sein könnte andere Wählergruppen auch
noch mal anspricht vielleicht eben dann
auch ältere Männer beispielsweise
ältere Männer ganz wichtige Zielgruppe
keinem würde ich den Enkeltrick eher
abnehmen als Robert Habeck in einem
zeitinterview nennt er den Abschied vom
kanzlertraum den schmerzhaftesten Tag in
seiner politischen Laufbahn und ich
finde gerade weil er verzichtet muss man
ihn auch mal feiern
[Musik]
die suffragettenbewegung Clara Zetkin
simunde Beaufort Alice Schwarzer
Legenden der Frauenbewegung doch es gibt
jemanden der sie alle überragt Robert
Habeck der größte feminist der je gelebt
hat er opfert seinen kanzlertraum und
wird sie Belohnung verprügelt erwerbst
darf er nur noch die Blusen der
Kanzlerin Bügeln was für eine Demütigung
vom Hause her kommt er hühnerschweine
weiß nicht was hast du Kühe melken ich
komme eher aus dem Völkerrecht ja ich
Völkerrecht du Schweinebauer doch
niemand sieht seine Tränen und erspart
uns allen bares Geld denn ein männlicher
Kanzler würde natürlich viel mehr Geld
verdienen deshalb im Namen aller Frauen
danke Robert du bist der geilste
[Musik]
finde ich auch Annalena B wäre die
jüngste Kanzlerin aller Zeiten und die
Kommentatoren fasziniert es total dass
sie auch noch Mutter von zwei kleinen
Kindern ist ist auf mein Riesenthema
junge Familie und macht wow wir werden
uns daran gewöhnen hier und fragen Sie
mich bitte nicht wie das technisch geht
eine heute-show aus dem November 2022
[Musik]
ein Wahnsinn also hatte Angela Merkel
die verschwundenen Wirecard Milliarden
die ganze Zeit in ihrer Dache versteckt
irre so ganz anderes Thema meine Damen
und Herren ein Jahr Kanzlerin beerbock
ziehen wir Bilanz und schalten dazu mal
live zum Kanzleramt zu Carolin Kebekus
Caroline was würden Sie sagen wie hat
Annalena baerbock das politische Berlin
sorry ich kann sie ganz schlecht
verstehen die Töchter von Annalena
baerbock die toben da vorne noch mit
ihren Freundinnen das ey seid ihr
bescheuert was macht ihr da mit der
Dienstlimousine von Robert Habeck
ja jetzt haben sie sie angezündet und
jetzt rennen sie weg ja ist auch ein
schwieriges Alter 7 und 11 ja Oliver ein
Jahr Kanzlerin baerbock und es ist
wirklich lustig wenn man sich noch mal
anguckt wie die Journalisten damals
reagiert haben auf ihre Kandidatur in
der Tat fehlt ihr die
regierungserfahrungen sie ist Mutter von
zwei kleinen Kindern ist verheiratet und
hat zwei Töchter die 40-Jährige
zweifachmutter zweifache Mutter zwei
Kinder zwei Kindern im Grundschulalter
Mutter von zwei Töchtern aber sie wissen
es ist ein Knochenjob und sie werden die
erste mit einer jungen Familie darüber
werden Sie sich Gedanken gemacht haben
nein
nein natürlich nicht sie ist ja eine
Frau wie soll sie sich da Gedanken
machen das ist noch total
Unverschämtheit hast du dir doch gut
überlegt Mäuschen Kanzlerin das ist ein
richtiger Beruf würde man man nie Fragen
oder Herr Söder sie haben doch vier
Kinder wir wollen Sie da auch noch
Kanzler werden naja wir Männer kriegen
Beruf und Familie halt unter einen Hut
nun machen wir nicht so ein Theater
davon ja weil er einfach nie zu Hause
seid ja das auch
damals hieß es baerbock greift nach dem
Kanzleramt alle waren ganz schockiert
über ihren Machthunger als Mutter noch
irgendwas werden wollen das ist doch
wieder die Natur in Wirklichkeit ist
Muttersein die beste Schule überhaupt
wer jeden Abend bibi und Tina hören muss
der lacht sich doch kaputt über so ein
G20-Gipfel auch dank Annalena baerbock
können heute immer mehr politiker:innen
Stolz sagen ich weiß was es bedeutet
Mutter von drei kleinen Kindern zu sein
wie schön also sie würden sagen ein Jahr
bärbock alles supi nein natürlich gab es
auch kleinere Krisen oder sagen wir mal
Irritationen zum Beispiel der Shitstorm
als sie während ihrer ersten
Neujahrsansprache die Playmobil
Ritterburg aufbauen musste oder die
schwere Krise mit Russland weil Putin
beim Staatsbesuch in ihrem Büro auf
diesen Legostein getreten ist aber ich
finde insgesamt kann sich die Bilanz
echt sehen lassen allein die vielen
neuen Kitas die wir bauen konnten jetzt
wo an die scheuer die halbe Milliarde
mautkohle von seinem privaten Geld
zurückgezahlt hat voll nett von ihm es
ist tatsächlich ein ganz anderes
Deutschland
bärbox neue personenschützerin ja ich
habe vorhin vielleicht die Töchter von
der Kanzlerin kurz angeschnauzt das tut
mir sehr sehr leid sehr sehr leid
Gott wie sehe ich denn 2022 aus
ich habe auch gehen lassen
beziehungsweise werde mich gehen lassen
naja genau ja die Zuschauer mittlerweile
fast alle versteckten Symbole hier bei
uns im neuen Studio gefunden
Illuminati Freimaurer Staatsfunk ist
alles dabei wann wollen wir denn die
eigentlichen Strippenzieher bekannt
geben
was es bei so vielen Abonnenten auf
Youtube boah also ich würde mich
ranhalten